pas un mot de m ben alors à l'avocat
dijonnais de muriel bolle à son arrivée
à la cour d'appel
ils espèrent encore que sa cliente sera
autorisé à regagner son domicile de
granges sur vologne
d'où elle vit éloigné depuis le mois de
juin dernier mais le refus de la chambre
de l'instruction ne l'étonnent pas ce
n'est pas forcément une surprise pour
nous puisque d'une part en ce qui
concerne les époux jacob ils avaient
eux-mêmes eu à gérer à un premier refus
et d'autre part nous avons compris qu'il
y a des éléments nouveaux qui sont
rentrés au dossier et il nous a été
indiqué que madame vols devaient être
réentendus muriel bolle pourrait être à
nouveau convoqué devant la juge
d'instruction dans le courant du mois
prochain
en attendant elle doit rester à
saint-honoré-les-bains où elle réside
depuis le 4 août dernier les deux autres
mises en examen dans cette affaire
jacqueline et marcel jacob la grand
tante et le grand oncle du petit grégory
avait eu été réentendu avant d'obtenir
un assouplissement de leur contrôle
judiciaire et de pouvoir rentrer dans
les vosges fin 2017 et toujours
concernant muriel bolle la chambre de
l'instruction a encore une autre requête
à examiner ses avocats ont demandé
l'annulation de sa mise en examen
il y aura donc une nouvelle audience ici
à la cour d'appel et ce sera le vendredi
9 février prochain